like realtalk here for a second they
have cotton balls in ancient Egypt my
early twenties I started getting
breakouts again which I thought was
weird I was like I'm an adult it's been
a struggle for me growing up with acne
all my life it's not my first rodeo I'm
looking forward to see what people have
done in the past and maybe kind of
implementing any of those into some sort
of routine
maybe the ancestors knew what they were
doing more than we do now cream of wheat
massage generous portions of sour or
curdled milk on face action baby oh no
is it too late to leave oh my god this
is so cool so like we can take it off it
look like Cleopatra this looks delicious
mix barley flour with butter into a
paste like consistency yeah this is a
tasty video we get in the top down oh
yeah my bad I'll rub butter on my whole
frickin body if you want me to alright
relax I'm also putting butter in my
pores I think your leftover this is goes
that's right that's why I lick the
amethyst and rub the slobbery stone
sounds a little embellished all over
offending areas could not be gross huh
how many other people before us have a
look at these amethyst ooh I did not
think of that you want to try mine
no I don't like that I'm making eye
contact with you in the mirror while
you're licking it uh-huh yeah she's
really working
[Music]
nope now get out of here with this mix
1tsp of goo goo goo poo powder with warm
water to make a poop taste it doesn't
say poo paise but I'm never saying it to
with every P word now leave for 10
minutes 10 minutes poo from a
nightingale
but faeces have diseases it's definitely
got in my mouth a little bit
oh my god stop talking I can't help it
oh she just keeps going it's this person
oh god I can't look at you because I was
gonna throw up we're getting shit-faced
don't you touch the poop on your face
the dry spot it's very small oh my god
this is literally how people get pink
eyes poop in their eye and I just did it
I really hate that I'm gonna say this
but my skin feels really good bottles
there's a deep cleansing face wash oh my
god that's what I want right now number
2 balancing toner we have for the PM
adapt alene gel acne treatment first I'm
using face wash oh thank god I can feel
the butter melting away calm ball gets
stuck in my beard hairs beard problems
this is like a nice gel
oh that guy that's no I put a crystal on
that should be fine you're gonna be acne
freaky thanks buddy
people got creative for their skincare
they had to try so many things I just
see what works this is my favorite one
so far so if you say ten out of ten
you'll be such a sellout I'm serious ten
out of ten
[Music]